everything you're doing is being  documented my great-great grandkids are  watching this right now  hey Jeremiah I think you have my DNA  please if I didn't buy the Jets please  execute that for me thank you the fact  that that just happened and the best  part is my great-great grandson or  daughter's gonna be like my name's not  [ __ ] Jeremiah I'm not a [ __ ] note  Radames I'm sorry  but everything you do every way you  interact with every customer every  product you build everybody you retweet  everybody you support everybody you're  giving a quote to for their book the  foreword anybody and everything you're  doing in today's world is being  documented and you are writing your  legacy right now